au canada l'homosexualité est illégale
jusqu'en 1969 il ya des gens qui ont été
discriminées arrêtés ou même condamné
juste parce qu'ils étaient gays le
gouvernement trudeau dit qu'il va
présenter des excuses l'automne prochain
mais des gens qui ont été condamnés
il y en eut le congrès
[Musique]
la réponse plus de 10000 il ya plus de
dix mille hommes qui ont été condamnés
parce qu'ils étaient guip juste des
hommes on les accusait de grossière
indécence ou de ce demi n'autorisons pas
l'homosexualité
nous disons simplement que nous n'allons
pas punir nous n'enverrons pas de police
dans les chambres à coucher pour voir ce
qui se passe
c'est le premier ministre trudeau père
qui a décriminalisé l'homosexualité en
mais après 69 et des gay qui ont
continué à subir des injustices comme
par exemple dans les forces canadiennes
il leur était interdit de servir
jusqu'en 1992
plusieurs ont été congédiés
en ce moment on ne sait pas si le canada
va effacer les condamnations dans les
dossiers judiciaires pour ça il faudra
un bar dont on sait pas non plus si les
excuses vont être accompagnée de
compensations financières en allemagne
au mois de mars
non seulement les condamnations ont été
effacés mais les hommes ont reçu des
indemnisations
vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]